مع قربي دخول الهدنه الخامسه يومها الثاني
اتهامات متبادله بين الجيش والدعم السريع
بخرق الاتفاق
سلاح الجو السوداني يعاود قصف اهداف في
الخرطوم بحري ومضادات تابعه للدعم السريع
ترد وفي دارفورد عنف قبلي يوسع دائره
المواجهات والامم المتحده تحذر من توزيع
اسلحه على المدنيين هناك
[موسيقى]
ومع استمرار المساعي الاقليميه والدوليه
لفتح باب التفاوض الاتحاد الافريقي يدعو
الاطراف لبدء مفاوضات فوريه البرهان يجدد
رفضه لقاح ميتي ويقول ان قوات الدعم
السريع مخيره بين الانقراض في الجيش او
قتال كل السودانيين وفي مقابله مع الجزيره
مستشار الحميطي يتهم من وصفهم بفلوول
النظام السابق بالسيطره على قرار الجيش
وعلى وقع تحذيرات من ارتدادات اقليميه
للصراع المبعوث الاممي يقول للجزيره ان
الجهه التي ترفض الاستجابه للحوار ستكون
معزوله دوليا ويشدد على ان تنفيذ اليه
محليه اقليميه دوليه لمراقبه وقف اطلاق
النار ضمانه لنجاح الهدى
والخارجيه الامريكيه تؤكد استمرار تواصلها
مع الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع لتطبيق وقف
اطلاق النار
على مهشار في بدايه اليوم الثاني في خامس
هدنه يشهدها السودان منذ الدلاع المواجهات
تستمر اتهامات الاطراف لبعضها البعض بخرق
الاتفاق وهي اتهامات تتوافق مع معطيات
الارض حيث تستمر الاشتباكات والمعارك في
الخرطوم
ومناطق اخرى
والاستطاعت تطورات ينضم الينا من وسط
الخرطوم مراسل الجزيره هيثم
وايضا معنا من ام درمان مراسلنا حسن رزاق
نبدا بهيثم كيف تبدو الاوضاع معك هيثم
الان في الخرطوم
هدوء يخيم على الخرطوم بعد يوم مشحوم
بالمواجهات التي بدات في وقت متاخر كان
الصباح المواجهات قليله وكانت اصوات
متقطعه للرصاص ولكن مع مرور الوقت ازدادت
حده الاشتباكات في اماكن مختلفه كانت هناك
مواجهات في بحري وايضا في الخرطوم في
منطقه جبل اولياء كانت هناك ايضا مواجهات
في وسط الخرطوم وكذلك في منطقه محيط
القياده العامه والقصر الجمهوري هذه
المواجهات تاتي في اليوم الاول للهدنه
الخامسه التي كانت يعني هي باعتبارها يعول
عليها ان تكون هدنه حقيقيه وهدنه يستطيع
من خلالها الناس ان يعني يلتقطوا انفاسهم
ويستطيع ان يقتلوا حاجتهم ولكنها ايضا
اصبحت مثلها كمثل سابقاتها من الهدن التي
اعشابتها الكثير من الخروقات المستمره على
مدار هذه المواجهات منذ بدايتها وبالتالي
اصبحت الان هي يعني مسار قلق بالنسبه سواء
كانت داخل المحلي هنا في السودان او
الخارج الذي بدات الاصوات فيه تتعالى
بضروره احترام هذه الهدن او هذه الهدنه
تحديدا وتحويلها الى يعني ربما مشروع
لتكون هدنه مستقبليه دائما لوقف دائما
اطلاق النار وهو متحاول كل الجهات الوصول
اليه عبر الضغط على طرفي الصراع حتى الان
ولكن كل هذه المحاولات هي حتى الان بات
بالفشل ولم تفلح في ان تكون ايا من هذه
الهدن هي هدنه حقيقيه على ارض الواقع نحن
نعيشه الان هو مواجهات مستمره في ظل حاله
التعنت يبدو من الطرفين ان الحسم العسكري
هو يبدو الاتجاه الذي تمضي عليه المسارح
العمليات هنا من خلال البيانات المتتاليه
سواء كان من قبل الجيش الذي يحكم يقول
بانه يحكم السيطره على الميدان وانه الان
يتقدم في مواقع كثيره او من خلال بيانات
الدعم السريعه التي ايضا تؤكد انها ما
زالت تحافظ على سيطرتها في المواقع التي
تسيطر عليها وتتهم الجيش المقابل بقصفها
بالطيران الجوي هذه هذا هو الحال في هذه
المعارك منذ نحو اسبوعين ونحن الان ندخل
الاسبوع على مكرره من دخول الاسبوع الثالث
حتى الان لا تلوح في الافق اي بوادر لحل
نهائي لهذه الازمه المتطاوله ماذا عن ام
درمان حسن الرزاق
منذ ان حل الليل والهدوء التام هو السائد
حاليا فهم درمان على الاقل في المناطق
التي تتواجد فيها في ام درمان لم نسمع
قرابه منذ اربع ساعات اي اصوات لمضادات
طائرات او لقذائف او طلقات او حتى تحليق
جوي لسلاح الجو السوداني فالهدوء التام
منذ ان حل الليل هو السائد على خلاف ما
كنا نرصد في النهار منذ الصباح الباكر
استيقظنا على دوي كثيف لمضادات وتحليق جوي
ورصاص واستمر حتى ساعات النهار بشكل متقطع
يزداد حينا ويقل حينا لكن منذ ان حل الليل
والهدوء التام هو السائد طبعا لا يمكن
تعميم هذه الحاله على كافه ام درمان ام
درمان هي مدينه كبيره جدا شاسعه مترامه
الاطراف ما يحدث هنا من اشتباكات عسكريه
قد لا يتاثر بيا المواطنين في شمال ام
درمان شمال ام درمان
الحاله هي هادئه منذ فتره طويله هادئه
نسبيا مستقرا نسبيا حتى ان مطار وادي
سيدنا وهو النظاره البديل الذي اصبح مطار
بديل لمطار الخرطوم كان يستقبل طوال تلك
الفترات طائرات من بريطانيا ومن فرنسا ومن
تركيا ايضا كان كان توقف لفتره بسبب بحسب
ما اشارت قوات المسلحه انه تم استهداف
طائره تركيا لكن تم استئناف العمل وبدا
اجلاء كثير من الرعايه منهم اندونيسيين
منهم اتراك وبالتالي المدينه هي مدينه
كبيره وما كنا نشهده من مواجهات جويه
تحديدا في ام درمان في جنوب ام درمان
الطبيعه المواجهات هي مواجهات جويه تحليق
طائرات ثم مضادات لكن على الارض مثل ما هو
في الخرطوم هنا غير في نطاق الجغرافي
محدود وايضا بشكل محدود فبالتالي
ما يمكن لا يمكن تعميم الحاله العامه على
كافه ام درمان باعتبار انه كبيره
وما يتاثر به المواطنين في جنوب ام درمان
قد لا لا يصل حتى لشمال هي منطقه هادئه
اذا هذا الوضع على الصعيد الميداني سؤال
لكيما واعود الى هيثم سياسيا الان اشرت
قبل قليل هيثم الى تمسك كل طرف بمواقفه هل
هذا يوحي للناس بان المساله ستطول
من واقع التصريحات التي ادلى بها قائد
للجيش عبد الفتاح البرهان انه لا سبيل
للتفاوض مع من اسمائها المتمرده وان وان
الجيش لن يتفاوض الا في حاله استسلام هذه
ما اسمها والقبول بالانضمام الى الجيش هذا
يعني ان خط التفاوض اغلق امام هذه
المحاولات التي تدعو الى التفاوض كان هناك
حديث لرئيس بعثه الامم المتحده قبل قليل
على الجزيره قد تحدث عن انه هذا الصراع
القائم لن يحل الا عبر الحوار ودعا الى
ضروره اشراك المجتمع الدولي هو خاصه الدول
الصديقه للسودان باستضافه قائدي الجيش
السوداني والدعم السريع لاجراء حوار مباشر
للتوسط وحل هذا الخلاف ولكن فيما يبدو
نبره هذا الرفض من قبل الجيش التي بدات
واضحه يعني تجعل هذا المشهد ربما سيطول
اذن شكرا لك هيثم كان بودنا ان نعود لحسن
ولكن هذا هو الموقف كما لخصه لنا هيثم من
الخرطوم شكرا لك
اذا وقد كانت المواجهات تركزت اليوم
الجمعه بشكل خاص في محاور العاصمه الخرطوم
التي شهدت اشتباكات عنيفه بمشاركه سلاح
الطيران والمدفعيه في محاور القصر
الجمهوري والخرطوم بحري ام درمان كذلك
وضحيه كفوري وجزيره توتي وقال مراسل
الجزيره ان سلاح الجو السوداني عاود قصف
اهداف في الخرطوم بحري فيما رده المضادات
التابعه للدعم السريع عليها وفي جنوبي
العاصمه الخرطوم شهدت منطقه جبل الاولياء
مواجهه مباشره بين قوات الجيش والدعم
السريع اما في اقليم دارفور فما تصاعد
العنف هناك نشر حاكم الاقليم قوات مشتركه
للفصل بين طرفي القتال لا سيما في الفجر
معنى الان من عماننا لوا فايز الدويري
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا وسهلا
بك هل هل المؤشرات الحاليه توحي باننا
سنكون امام مواجهات ستطول في السودان
يعني دعني ابدا كالاتي لا يملك اي طرف من
طرفي الصراع القدره على تحقيق الحسم
العسكري في المستوى الاستراتيجي قد يستطيع
ان يحقق ذلك الجيش يستطيع ان يحقق ذلك
ودعني اذا قلت المستوى الاستراتيجي مستوى
السودان المستوى العمليات في هذه الحاله
يكون مدينه الخرطوم قد يستطيع بعد فتره
زمنيه قد تطول ان يستعيد السيطره على
الخرطوم ولكن حتى اذا استعاد السيطره على
الخرطوم ما هي المقالات واين ستذهب قوات
الرد السريع اذا لا يملك اي طرف القدره
على الحسم على في المستوى الاستراتيجي وقد
يحققه الجيش في مستوى العمليات ولكن ذلك
لا ينهي الحرب لان الحرب ستنتقل الى
الولايات الاخرى
ستدخل السودان في دوامه لها بدايه وليس
لها نهايه النقطه الوحيده الفرقه عليهم ان
يخفضوا من وتيره الرفض المطلق للطرف الاخر
لا يوجد امكانيه لمعادله صفريه انما
المعادله هي خاسر خاسر وبالتالي عليهم ان
يحددوا من الغلواء والرفض للطرف الاخر
والعيش في اوهام القدره على الانتصار
وبالتالي حتى يكون هناك مخرج للحفاظ على
ما تبقى من الدوله السودانيه اذا حسمت
الامور في الخرطوم هل معنى ذلك انها حسمت
في باقي المناطق بالضروره
ليس بالضروره ليس بالضروره لماذا يعني لن
ندخل في لغه الارقام لانها غير مثبته هناك
تاريخ طويل من الصراع منذ عام
1957 من القرن الماضي
والصراع مع الجنوب اخر 23 سنه ثوره مستمره
صراع دارفور من 2003 ولا يوجد قدره على
القضاء على تلك النزاعات المحليه فكيف
الان اذا اصبح لديهم جيش وجيش موازي وان
يتميز السودان بالثنائيه العربي والافريقي
المسيحي والمسلم اصحاب واتباع الديانات
الاسلاميه والاثنيين القبائل المتناحره لا
يملك اي طرف القدره على حجم الصراع بطريقه
عسكريه لكن عليهم ان يعودوا الى شيء من
العقلانيه
وان يلتقوا في نقطه وسطيه
تبقي على ما تبقى من السودان الان الوضع
في دارفور ايضا تفجر هل هناك خشيه من ان
مناطق التوتر السابقه ستعود الى الاستيعال
من جديد في ظل ظروف الحاليه
يا سيدي الان يعني الدارفور تقريبا 500
الف كيلو متر مربع بمساحه فرنسا السيطره
عليها مستحيله القبائل المتجذره بها قبائل
كبيره جدا بينها صراعات فحتى الان القبائل
لم تدخل بصوره جاذبه باستثناء الجنينه على
على طريق القتال او الاقتتال وبالتالي حتى
داخل دارفور قد لا يمكن السيطره عليها
ولكن الاسوا اذا ما نجح الجيش لاستعاده
الخرطوم على قوات الرد السريع ان تنكفي
باتجاه الغرب الى معقلها التي انطلقت منه
وهي انطلقت من دارفور وهنا ندخل في
سيناريو ليبيا طرابلس وبرقه
شكرا جزيلا لك فايز الدويري من عمان
هذا وقد قدرت الامم المتحده عدد ضحايا
العنف القبليه الغربيه البلاد في اقليم
دارفور بنحو 100 شخص منذ الاثنين الماضي
كما تحدثت عن رصد توزيع اسلحه على
المدنيين هناك
وتجددت النزاعات القبليه في الولايه بعد
اندلاع المعارك بين قوات الدعم السريع
والجيش السوداني وادت هذه الاشتباكات منذ
بدايتها قبل اسبوع الى مقتل العشرات وقد
اظهرت صور بثها شهود عيان مشاهد من اثار
الدمار الذي لحق بالمحل التجاريه والمنازل
السكنيه في مدينه الجنينه بسبب الاشتباكات
التي وقعت يوم امس
ومع امتداد القتال الى منطقه الجنينه
غربيه اقليم دارفور يستحضر السودانيون تلك
الرقعه من بلادهم التي لطالما كانت مسرحا
لصراعات بين الجماعات المسلحه والحكومه
نتعرف اكثر في هذا التقرير على هذا
الاقليم
يقع اقليم دارفور في الجزء الغربي من
السودان وتقدر مساحته بخمس مساحه البلاد
يقارب عدد سكان الاقليم 9 ملايين ونصف
مليون شخص ويسكنه عدد كبير من القبائل
ابرزها الفور والمساليت والزغاوه
والريزيجات وترجع تسميه الاقليم الى قبيله
الفور ودارفور تعني موطن الفور تحد
الاقليم اربع دول من الشمال الغربي ليبيا
ومن الغرب تشاد ومن الجنوب الغربي افريقيا
الوسطى ومن الجنوب دوله جنوب السودان
ينقسم اداريا الى خمس ولايات شمال دارفور
وعاصمتها مدينه الفاشر وجنوب دارفور
وعاصمتها مدينه نيالا وغرب دارفور
وعاصمتها مدينه الجنينه وشرق دارفور
وعاصمتها مدينه الضعين ووسط دارفور
وعاصمتها مدينه زالنجي
يمتاز الاقليم بثروه حيوانيه كبيره وكثيرا
ما عرف صراعات بين الرعاه والمزارعين غتت
الانتماءات القبليه نشطت في دارفور جماعه
مسلحه منها جيش تحرير السودان اصيل عبد
الواحد نور وينظر اليه على انه القوه
القتاليه المهمه الوحيده المتبقيه داخل
دارفور حيث يعتمد قائده على دعم قبيله
الفور وحركه العدل والمساواه بزعامه جبريل
ابراهيم وتكونت من مسلحين معظمهم من غير
العرب اضافه الى جيش تحرير السوداني
بزعامه مني اركوميناوي وتشكلت هذه الجماعه
نتيجه لانقسام قبلي بجيش تحرير السودان
كما ارتبطت بقتال ما تسمى فصائل الجنجويد
المسلحه المتهمة بارتكاب فضائع في دارفور
[موسيقى]
سياسيا دعا غزالي عثمان رئيس دوله جزر
القمر القمر رئيس الدوله الحاليه للاتحاد
الافريقي كلا من عبد الفتاح البرهان ومحمد
حمدان دقلو الى وقف القتال بشكل فوري
واحترام حياه المدنيين السودانيين
والرعايه الاجانب كما دعا الطرفين الى بدء
المفاوضات فورا للوصول الى حل سلمي للازمه
الراهنه وحتى الرئيس الحالي للاتحاد
الافريقي ما وصفها بالجهات الفاعله في
المجتمع الدولي على دعم الجهود الاتحاد
لاعاده السلام والاستقرار الى السودان
من جهتها نقلت القوات المسلحه السودانيه
عن القائد العام للجيش الفريق عبد الفتاح
البرهان القول انه لا يمكن الجلوس مع من
وصفه بقائد الميليشيا لانه يقود تمردا
ويجب حسمه واضاف البرهان انه لا مجال لهذه
الميليشيا الا الزوال عبر التفاوض بشان
كيفيه استيعابها داخل القوات المسلحه او
قتالها من الشعب السوداني كافه حسب تعبيره
واوضح البرهان انه لا يمكن لمن سماها
ميليشيا قبليه ان تتحدث عن الديمقراطيه
والتحول المدني
في الاثناء قال الناطق الرسمي لوزاره
الخارجيه السودانيه عبد الرحمن خليل
للجزيره ان وكيل وزاره الخارجيه دفع الله
الحاج علي سيتوجه يوم غد الى الرياض في
زياره لمده يومين يلتقي خلالها وزير
الخارجيه السعوديه لنقل رساله من رئيس
مجلس السياده عبد الفتاح البرهان الى
القياده السعوديه
وسيتوجه وكيل وزاره الخارجيه السودانيه
بعد السعوديه الى القاهره حيث سيلتقي وزير
الخارجيه المصريه سامح شكري وينقل رساله
الى الرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي بالرئيسي
مجلس السياده عبد الفتاح البرهان ويزور
بعد القاهره عددا من العواصم الافريقيه
في المقابل قال يوسف عزه المستشار السياسي
لقائد قوات الدعم السريع للجزيره ان هدفهم
الوحيد هو منع عوده النظام السابق للحكم
مشيرا الى ان هناك تنظيما داخل الجيش يضم
عناصر النظام السابق وانه هو من اتخذ قرار
الحرب واضاف عزه ان عدوهم ليس القوات
المسلحه وانما هو فلول النظام السابق
هنالك خلايا وتنظيم هنالك تنظيم اسلامي
لديه
معروف لدينا داخل الجيش هذا التنظيم هو
الذي اتخذ قرار الحرب هذا التنظيم يجبر
البرهان والبرهان متامر معهم هو الذي يدير
الحرف هو الذي اعلنه هو الذي يحرك القوات
من خلال الضباط الاسلاميين الذين يديرون
المعركه هذا هذه حقيقه علمها الشعب
السوداني وهي سبب الحرب لاننا طالبنا
بتنقيه صفوف الجيش صفوف القوات المسلحه في
عمليه الاصلاح من عناصر النظام
الدكتور ابراهيم مخير رئيس مكتب الشؤون
الخارجيه بالمكتب الاستشاري لقائد قوات
الدعم السريه محمد حمدان حميد اهلا وسهلا
بك لو انطلقنا مما قاله الان السيد يوسف
عزت كيف يمكن ان
نستثير هذا الكلام في حين ان الكل كان في
شراكه مع بعض الان اصبح كل طرف يذكر عيوب
الطرف الاخر وكانه يكتشفها الان
الحقيقه ان
الثوره عام 2019
غيرت هذا الامر
لانها فرضت واقع جديد
السودانيين كما تعلم دخلوا في حوار
يحاولون ان ينقلوا
ينقلوا النظام السابق
الديكتاتوري العسكري الذي استمرت 30 عام
الى نظام ديمقراطي هذا الحوار استمر لفتره
طويله بين اخذ ورد ولكن من تاثر به
وظن انه لن يعني يجد
مخرجا
في فيما ارصد
في مرصد مساله السيطره على مواقع النفوس
هو الاسلاميين الاسلاميين راوا في كل هذا
الحوار الذي اتى الى ان يكون الاتفاق
الايطالي ارى فيه النزعه لنفوزهم
وبالتالي هم عملوا على ان يسقطوا هذا
الاتفاق ومن ثم انقلبوا على النظام في
السودان ولكن احميتي كذلك لا يمكن ان نفصل
بينه وبين النظام السابق هو كان جزءا من
النظام السابق يعني لا يمكن الحديث هكذا
بهذه البساطه
البساطه بصراحه انه احنا لابد ان نفهم انه
حلم التين مره بفترات كثيره من التطور
التطور السياسي
من معارض في صفوف
في الصفوف في دارفور
بمجموعه بسيطه الى اتفاق مع الحكومه
السودانيه عمر البشير ثم تطور الى
جندي في القوات المسلحه ثم
تطور قوات الدعم السريع لتصير قوات معروفه
مهام اولا كانت التصدي للمعارضه المسلحه
ثم تطورت هذه
القوات لتلعب ادوارا في
مقاومه ومكافحه الهجره الغير شرعيه وتهريب
عبر الاسلحه ثم في مهام دوليه فهذه هي
مسيره مسيره لفريق
اول محمد حمدان دقلوه تعكس تطور هذا الرجل
وهذا الرجل ليس جامد في مرحله معينه ثم
انه ليس اسلاميا المنشا اي لم يتخرج من
مدرسه الاسلاميه الترابي وغيرهم انما اتى
اتت به
الاقدار الى
النظام ثم طور نفسه ليصبح انسانا متفهما
واسعا مدركا لما يحدث في السودان بطبيعته
وفطرته
السودانيه البسيطه
حتى حتى لو لم يكن اسلاميا منشا ومر
بمراحل تطور ونضج سياسي مثل ما تقول لا
يمكن ان ننكر انه كان يضع اليد في اليد مع
القوات المسلحه لقمع المتظاهرين وكان جزءا
من انقلاب على حكومه حكومه مدنيه يعني هو
لا يمكن ان يتنصل من كل الاعباء المرحله
الماضيه
ليس حقيقه
القمع المتظاهرين تكونت له لجنه بقياده
قانون يعني محترم هو السيد اديب وهذا
الرجل
يعني لم يثبت اي
تورط للفريق في هذه العمليات بنفسه بل تم
القبض على اسلاميين ووضعهم في السجن والان
هؤلاء الذين تم القبض عليهم تم اخراجهم من
السجون في هذه الفوضى الخلاقه التي صنعها
الاسلاميه
والباسهم الملابس العسكريه وهم يقاتلون في
الميدان فالحقائق
مشكله الوضع السوداني وخاصه ما يخص
المجتمع الدولي انه ليس هنالك الدقيق من
المعلومات المعلومات غير دقيقه يعني
اغلبها
يعني معلومات مزيفه او او
ركيكه او تعتمد على ناشطين سياسيين وليس
على احصائيات وحقائق فنحن نعلم ان السيد
اديب لم يوجه اي ازمه للاتهام ولم توجه له
اي محكمه الدوليه كانت او محليه اصابع
الاتهام في اي قضيه داخل السودان اما في
مساله مجال التغيير السلطه نعم قد اصطفى
مع الشعر السوداني وكان الشباب يحتفون له
يعني
وهم متحمسون له وظل يلعب نفس الدور الى ان
اخيرا وقع على الاتفاق الاطاري حينما
انسحب الجيش هذه حقائق لا يمكن نكرانها
انا اقول
وربما الاشكال ربما هو الاشكال هو في هذه
النقطه تحديدا ان حمايه اراد ان يضع رجلا
في السلطه ورجلا كانه مع الشارع في
التغيير والانتقال الديمقراطي وهذا كان
مربك لاي سلطه
ليس هناك ارباك هناك عمليه مشرف عليها
المجتمع الدولي كل المكونات الدوليه
الموجوده وهي موجوده على الاضبارات
ومراقبه دوليا وليس هناك
قال انه
منسحب من العمليه السياسيه
ونفذ هذا وهو وقع الاتفاق ولكن الجيش سحب
ما اقوله هنا يجب علينا جميعا ان ننظر الى
الامور بصوره مختلفه لا يمكن العوده للخلف
لا يمكن ان تضع دوله في القرن في عام 2023
داخل تحت اطار حكم الديكتاتور العسكري
اسلامي متطرف نحن لا نقاتل الجيش لان
الجيش مؤسسه واحده من الاخطاء واحده من
الاخطاء التي الحكومه المدنيه ان هي حاولت
ان تفكك المنظومه النظاميه او القوات
الامنيه وغيره وهذا غير صحيح شكرا لك
دكتور ابراهيم خير من لندن ينضم الينا
الان من العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم عبد
الباسط ادريس الصحفي والمحلل السياسي لو
انطلقنا مما كان يقوله الان الدكتور
ابراهيم الخير
هل هل
هذا التركيز على ان الصراع الان هو مع
فلول النظام السابق ومن الاسلاميين تحديدا
هل يمكن ان يلقى صدا وتفاهما من الاطراف
غير السودانيه
اعتقد انه الصراع الان
المسلحه الان هو استراحه تم تعريفه من قبل
الجيش بان
القوات الدعم السريع وغيرها تمردوا على
الجيش السوداني لان هذه القوه تتبع لي
القائد العام بموجب قانونها وبالتالي
التوصيف الصحيح ان هذا هو تمرد الان وحتى
قيد الجيش اتهمه اليوم بانه حاول الانقلاب
على على السلطه اما الحديث عن عن هذه
المعركه هي بالاساس مع مع الاسلاميين هي
محاوله لاستدرار العواطف
الهروب
بالحقائق الى الى الامام لان معروف ان
الدعم السريع كونه الرئيس البشير في
واجازه قانونه برلمان النظام السابق
وبالتالي الجيش السوداني هو الان يعمل على
تصحيح هذه الاخطاء وفقا
غير الجيش نفسه في احد المخاطبات العسكريه
بانه سيعمل على تصحيح كل اخطاء النظام
السابق بالقوات المسلحه
والمشكل انه المشكله
فقط سيد ادريس كيف يمكن له ان يصحح مثل
هذا الوضع
والبرهان وضع يده في يد حميدتي في كل
مراحل الماضيه سمح للدعم السريع بان ينتشر
وبان تزداد قوته بان يصبح شريكا في الحكم
بان يصبح نائبا له هذا لا يدل على خطوات
للتصحيح
صحيح ولكن الوضع الذي كان عليه الدعم
السريع هو كان هو موازيه وقد اسس الاتفاق
الايطالي وقد اسس كل المساعي الدوليه التي
كانت تعمل وفق اعداد الوثيقه الايطاليه
الى ان يكون هذا
الفصيل الذي يتبع للجيش جيشا قائما بذاته
صحيح ان البرهان قد مكن للدعم السريع
بهذا الانتشار الواسع وبهذه الكيفيه والان
تتم معالجه تصحيح هذا الوضع على النحو
الذي نراه الان ولكن عندما كان الدعم
السريع احد الفصائل التي
انحازت للتغيير في 2019 لم يكن بهذه
الضخامه ولم يكن بهذا النفوس معروف ان غير
الدعم السريع قد اختطف هذه القوه وسعى لان
يعمل عبرها علاقات خارجيه منفصله ويحصل
على تسليح من دوله بعينها ارادت ان تخيل
بتوازن القوى الاستراتيجي باضعاف الجيش
السوداني وتسليحه وتزويد قوات الدعم
السريع بعدد من الاسلحه ومعدات تحديدا
تحديدا
سمح له بان يتمدد لم يتحفظ على ذلك لم
يوقفه عند حده الى ان وصلت الامور الى الى
هذه النقطه التي لم يعد بمقدوره ان
يواجهها الان
نعم صحيح هذا هو الان الفتاح البرهان
يتحمل جزء كبير من هذه المسؤوليه باعتبار
ان هذه القوه عندما استلم السلطه لم تقوم
بهذا النفوس وهذا الحجم وبالتالي عليه الا
ان يصحح هذا الوضع وان ان يعمل على انهاء
كل مظاهر ملسنه الدوله
ويعني يكون هنالك جيش وطني مهني واحد
يتم دمج جميع الحركات والفصائل المسلحه في
الجيش وان يحتكر الجيش العنف وان يكون على
مسافه واحده من جميع السودانيين ويعبر عن
جميع السودانيين والسودانيات هذا هو
التحدي الذي امام البرهان ليصحح الخطا
الذي ورثه اولا والخطا الذي اعتماد فيه
ثانيه تصريحات البرهان اليوم بانه لا مجال
لصلح مع هذا الفصيل
المتمرد هل
الكل يتساءل الان ما اذا كان بقدره الجيش
والبرهان على الحسم العسكري مع ان
الكثيرين يشككون في هذه الامكانيه
البرهان يقول ذلك عينه على على ميدان
المعركه هو يجي الصعوبه في التسويق
فكره الحل السلم المتفاوض عليه
لجنوده وقواعده بالتالي يدرك ان
المزاج العام العسكريه والرايه العامه
العسكري هو يعتقد بان المعركه في نهايتها
وانه غاما بحسم التمرد وبالتالي اي محاوله
لاعاده احيائه الدعم السريع بنسخته
القديمه مره اخرى عن طريق التفاوض تمثل
هزيمه معنويه وهزيمه حقيقيه واستراتيجيه
للدوله السودانيه لانه مثل هذا الحل من
شانه ان يرحل الازمه الى الامام لتنفجر
مره اخرى ربما في نظام اخر او تعقد
المشكله السوداني باكثر مما هو عليه الان
ولذلك اعتقد ان البرهان لا يستطيع الان ان
يقول انه سيذهب الى التفاوض مع حمايه تي
في ظل هذه الاجواء الماسله الان ولكن ايضا
رفض التفاوض يبدو اشكال يعني اذا اخذنا ما
قاله مبعوث الامم المتحده الى السودان قال
ان اي طرف يرفض التفاوض حتى وان انتصر حتى
وان انتصر سيصبح معزولا دوليا هل البرهان
في وارد ان يفعل ذلك
هذه واحده من المتغيرات الكبيره جدا في
الخطاب الدولي الحديث الذي ادلى به فولكر
للجزيره الاخباريه اليوم هو حمله تحديدا
صريحا بان من يرفض ذلك وربما هو يعني عبد
الفتاح البرهان بصوره رئيسيه ولكن ما لا
يجب ان ينساه
السودانيين والسودانيات ان فولكر نفسه هو
يعتبر جزء من الازمه لانه ادار هذا الملف
مع مجموعه الرباعيه الدوليه بطريقه خاطئه
وتخلى عن مهامه الاساسيه المنصوص عليها
بموجب الاتفاقيه بين الامم المتحده
والسودان بما في ذلك تخليه عن
جلب الدعم المالي والوجستي وانفاست
اتفاقيه سلام
بنده ترتيبات الامنيه وتجهيز حتى قوات
حمايه المدنيين في دارفور التي كان من
المقرر ان تنتشر وتحل محل بيحصل الامميه
الافريقيه لحفظ السلام
البلاد وبالتالي انحاز لاطراف سياسيه
بعينها وعزل اطراف اخرى وفجر الاوضاع في
الاقاليم
واراد ان يسوق الاتفاق بمعزل عن قوى الريف
والقوه الاجتماعيه والمدنيه الاخرى ولذلك
عندما وحتى عندما بدات المفاوضات بين
المكونه العسكري لتحديد اجيال زمنيه لدمج
الدعم السريع خرجوا واخترح الجيش ان يكون
عامين لثلاث اعوام خرج هو وغال ان الدعم
السريع يمكن ان يدمج خلال 10 اعوام
وبالتالي هو يتحمل جزء كبير جدا من
المسؤوليه
وجسم مما الت اليه الاوضاع الان في البلاد
وان اراد الان ان يسوق الاتفاق ان يسوغ
للعمليه السياسيه السابقه وان اراد الان
ان يمضي في ذات المساله القديم اعتقد انه
سيدفع بالبلاد الى مزيد من الانفجارات
والى مزيد من الحروب لان هذا المسار اثبت
فشله واثبت ان جميع كتله مغدره جدا من
السود انيين والسودانيات يرفضونه هذا
الاتفاق الذي حاول تسويقه ادى الى هذه
الحرب اللعينه شكرا لك يا عبد الباسط
ادريس من الخرطوم
وفي هذا السياق حذر ستيفان دجاليك المتحدث
باسم الامين العام للامم المتحده من ان
طول امد القتال في السودان سيزيد من مخاطر
زعزعه الاستقرار الاقليمي مؤكدا اهميه
استمرار كل الدول والمنظمات المعنيه
بالوضع السوداني في استخدام نفوذها لوقف
القتال
لم يكن هناك فرق حقيقي بين موقف الامين
العامي ووزير الخارجيه الامريكي فيما
يتعلق بالحاجه لمواصله ارسال رساله موحده
لكلا الطرفين سواء كانت من الولايات
المتحده او دول اخرى في المنطقه او في اي
مكان اخر لدينا جميعا نقاط اتصال مختلفه
مع الطرفين واعتقد ان الكل يستخدمها
لتحقيق نفس الهدف كلما طال هذا القتال
زادت مخاطر زعزعه الاستقرار الاقليمي
الان معنا من روبيا البروفيسور محمد الحسن
نبات مدير ديوان رئيس مفوضيه الاتحاد
الافريقي اهلا وسهلا بك الكل يتحدث عن
ضروره وقف القتال واعطاء فرصه للوساطه هل
يمكن الاتحاد الافريقي ان يلعب دورا مميزا
في هذا الاتجاه
ات الافريقيه
هو حل الازمات الاف
ريقيه
المجهول الافريقي
اقل
وحول هذه النقطه بالذات هنالك شبه اجماع
دولي على ان الازمه السودانيه او الليبيه
او الكونغوليه او الى غيرها يجب ان يعمد
ان تقارن من وجهه نظر افريقيه الا ان
الاتحاد الافريقي ايضا يعرف جيدا انه
بحاجه ماسه الى مختلف مكونات المنظومه
الدوليه سواء كانت الامم المتحده او
الجامعه العربيه او الاتحاد الاوروبي او
المنظمه الجهويه
بعض القوه العظمى مثل
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ومثل ايضا بعض
الدول العربيه ذات الدوري الاساسي سواء
كانت المملكه العربيه السعوديه او
الامارات العربيه المتحده او قطر او غيرها
من دول الدول العربيه لا تشاني او ذات
الاهتمام الكبير بالازمه السودانيه وعلى
هذا الاساس نظم الاتحاد الافريقي بعد
التشاور مع
اجتماعا عاما حضره الامين العام المتحده
وحضره وزير خارجيه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وحضره الامير العام للجامعه
العربيه وحضره المسؤول الاوروبي للشؤون
الخارجي وحضره وزير الخارجيه المصري
وحضرته احضره عده وزراء من الدول المجاوره
للسودان
وانشا هذا الاجتماع اليه دوليه وهذه
الاليه الدوليه التي يتغاوت
نشاط واعضائها في المنظومه التي تشكلت نحن
ننظم لهم اجتماعا يوم الثاني من مايو في
اديس ابابا بالممثلين الدائمين لكل هؤلاء
وسيضع هذا الاجتماع
خارطه طريق محدده
لمقاربه الازمه ولكن عفوا عفوا سيدي نبات
للتوضيح اجتماع اثنين مايو
لاطراف الصراع في السودان
لا
لمكونات المنظومه الدوليه التي تشكلت يوم
20 ابريل الماضي
ولكن ولكن هذه الاطراف الدوليه التي اشرت
اليها
ذكرها السيد فولكر ايضا الامم المتحده
الايجاد السعوديه بريطانيا الامارات انت
اشرت الى دول اخرى من اين يمكن ان نبدا
هذا هو المشكل
يبدو ان نجتمع اولا لنحدد موقفا محددا
واحدا قبل ان ندعو الاطراف الان الاطراف
ندعوهم لمساله
مستعجله جدا وهي ايقاف الاقتتال هي وقف
الاقتتال هي وقف اطلاق النار لانه بدون
وقف اطلاق النار لا يمكن لا ان نجمع
الاطراف ولا ان ناتي بالاغاثه الانسانيه
للخرطوم للشعب للشعب السوداني في مهما
كانت المدينه التي هو فيها الخرطومه
وغيرها من المدن المتضرره تضررا فادحا
بالصراع المسلح
ايضا سيد لباد اشار الى اليه مراقبه هل
تساطرنه نفس التحليل لانك ايضا تشير الى
انه لا يمكن ان نفعل شيئا قبل وقف اطلاق
النار هل يمكن فعلا التوصل الى اليه
مراقبه في ظل اصرار كل طرف على ما يظنه
قدره على الحزم العسكري
نحن الان امام موقف يقول في طرف كل على
حده انه متكبث
على ولكن
يواصلان تبادل الاتهامات بالخروقات
وبالتالي
ان يكون هناك تكون هناك
مستعجله
للاشتراك على
احترامي وقف
كليه الطرفين والا فسنبقى ندور في دوامه
الاتهامات
المتبادله وبالتالي في الاجتماع الذي يدعو
له يوم
السبت من مايو لممثلي كل هذه الاطراف
الدوليه هو ان نتفق على صيغه للمراقبه
سريعه
اثنين مايو هل لديكم على الاقل ولو مؤشرات
اوليه على ان الطرفي الصراع مستعدان
للتجاوب مع مساعي من هذا القبيل
رئيس مفوضيه الاتحاد الافريقي الاتصال مع
السيد مع الجنر
وكلاهما صرح بصريح العباره له انه يوافق
على تمديد الهدنه
72 ساعه وبالتالي
كافيه
لاعطاء المهله للاجتماع الذي يبث في مساله
المراقبه واذا دعت الضروره في منهم ان
يمدد سنطلب ذلك لن نخجل من ذلك
ما هو المهم هو ان يقف
ان يحل وقف اطلاق النار محل الصراع المسلح
لانه هدام بالنسبه للسودان
ضد كل المحاولات الدوليه من اجل مساعده
الشعب السوداني في احلال السلام وفي
الانتقال الى مرحله ما بعد السلام
هل ننتظر يعني بعد اجتماع اثنين مايو ان
يذهب وفد مثلا عن هذا الاجتماع للقاء
الطرفين في الخرطوم مثلا
ظروف قبل ما ذهبنا لان حتى في الاتحاد
الافريقي كنا لليوم الثاني
لما شب الحريق كنا مستعدين وانا صرحت بذلك
بالجزيره اننا كنا على اوهبت الاستعداد
ولكن لم يكن هنالك فارح لاستقبالنا ولا
ايضا استعداد من الطرف من جانب الاطراف في
وقف اطلاق النار اذا توفرت
فنروح بالنسبه للاتحاد الافريقي لدي
نا بكل الحاح ان يتشبث بوقف اطلاق النار
لاعطائي فرصه اكثر للسلام ولاعمال
القرارات التي تم تقريرها يوم 20 والتي
ستتركز في خريطه الطريق ان شاء الله
هل لديكم ايه مخاوف تتعلق باتساع رقعه
المعارك لان مع ما يجري في دارفور ربما
القصه اذا استمرت لفتره اطول لن تصبح فقط
حمايه برهان ستصبح نزاعات في اكثر من مكان
داخل السودان نفسه
وبمشارب مختلفه
المخاوف يا اخي كثيره جدا لان كل انسان
يمكن ان يقرر الوقت الذي يقوم فيه يبدا
الحرب ولكن لا احد يمكن ان يقرر عندما
تشبني نيران الحرب بتاريخ ايقافها الخطر
في التدخلات الاجنبيه وتدوين الازمه قائم
الخلاء المخاطر في انتشاره انتشار العدوى
والفوضى الى دول الجوار قائم
المخاوف من ان نسي الحرب طابعه حرب
القبليه القائم
قائمه ما لم يوقف حالا الصراع المسلح وان
يرجع السودانيون الى رشدهم ايا كانوا ثم
ثم ان لدينا اهتمام اخر نبدا نشر اليه
تغيير الطبقه السياسيه والقوه السياسيه من
مختلف المشارب ومن مختلف الاطياف عن
الصراع وعن مشاركه بالحل هو خطا ايضا فادح
الامر ليس فقط بيد العسكريين العسكريون
مكون من مكونات المعالي السودانيه فلابد
ويمتاز هذه الفرصه لان اناشد القوه
السياسيه بمختلفه اصنافها بان تلقي بكل
ثقلها من اجل ايقاف ايقاف الاقتتال
والرجوع الى طاوله المفاوضات وفتحي
وفتح الطرق لمساعداتي الانسانيه التي
يحتاجها الشعب السوداني اكثر من اي وقت
مضى شكرا لك محمد الحسن لباس مدير ديوان
رئيس مفوضيه الاتحاد الافريقي من نيروبي
هذا وقد قال رئيس بعثه الامم المتحده
للدعم في السودان بولكربرج انه تمت دعوته
دول المنطقه المهمه لاستضافه البرهان
وحميته للتوسط بينهما اضاف بيرس في مقابله
مع الجزيره ان المخرج الان من الازمه في
السودان والتوصل الى هدنه واليه واضحه
بمراقبه تنفيذها
في وقف اطلاق نار في هدنه
هدنه يعني مشروطه
او خلينا
منظم يعني باليه لمراقبه
الهدنه او وقفه بلاك هاش لازم تشارك فيه
طبعا
الاتراف المتسارعين
يجب ان يجتمع ان يشارك فيه يعني بالموني
يعني
رقابه
بمراقبه بمراقبه اف بمراقبه الهدنه يعني
لازم تشارك فيه بعض الاطراف الدوليه ويمكن
من اهم يعني اطراف محليه
قد حذر فولكر في مقابلته مع الجزيره من
انه في حال رفض اي جهه في السودان
الاستجابه للحوار فانها ستكون عندها
معزوله دوليا حتى لو انتصرت في الحرب
كل دول الممتعه ودول العالم يعني لازم ان
لازم ان يقولون يعني بكل القوه انه اذا
استمر هذه
الحاله
فحتى اذا انتصر جهه على جهه ثانيه
فستكون
ستكون جهه مرفود دوليا يعني اذا اذا اذا
جحا هلا
ترفض المفوضات اذا جهت ترفت المسالخه فما
ما تكون مقبوله يعني دوليا واكليميا وانا
بتات وهذا اهم اجتماعيا او مجتمعيا في
السودان
نائب المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه ان
واشنطن تتواصل مع الجيش السوداني وكذلك مع
قوات الدعم السريع من اجل الالتزام بوقف
اطلاق النار ومواصله تمديده وكذبتين في
مؤتمر الصحفي اهميه الوصول الى مرحله يمكن
فيها تحقيق وقف دائما للاعمال الغذائيه
وتقديم المساعدات الانسانيه
نتواصل باستمرار مع الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع لمواصله تمديد وقف اطلاق
النار والوصول الى مرحله يمكن فيها تحقيق
وقف دائم للاعمال العدائيه وتقديم
المساعدات الانسانيه الحد من العنف سيسمح
باستمرار عمليات اجلاء المواطنين
الامريكيين الى جانب رعايه حلفائنا
وشركائنا الى بر الامان
الجدير بالتنويه انه منذ اندلاع القتال في
الرابع عشر من الشهر الحالي وافق طرفان
نزاع في السودان الجيش والدعم السريع على
خمس هدن فشلت كلها حتى الان في وقف
الاشتباكات بين الجانبين
الاعلان عن الهدنه الاولى لاربع وعشرين
ساعه جاء بعد اربعه ايام من اندلاع القتال
بين الجيش والدعم السريع لكن الهدنه التي
جاءت بعد اتصالات امريكيه ونداءات دوليه
سرعان منهارت بعد دقائق فقط من دخولها حيز
التنفيذ في اليوم التالي اعلنت الاليه
الثلاثيه المكونه من الاتحاد الافريقي
ومنظمه الايجاد والامم المتحده ان الطرفي
الصراع اعلن التزامهما بتنفيذ وقف اطلاق
نار لمده 24 ساعه لكنها شهدت ايضا اتهامات
متبادله من الطرفين بخرقها في العشرين من
ابريل اعلن كل من الجيش والدعم السريع
موافقتهما على دعوه الامين العام للامم
المتحده انطونيو غوتيريش للالتزام بهدنه
لثلاثه ايام بمناسبه عيد الفطر والتي شهدت
كسابقاتها خروقات متقطعه من الطرفين
في اليوم العاشر للقتال اعلن وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه موافقه الطرفين النزاع
بعد اتصالات مكثفه على وقف لاطلاق النار
72 ساعه ادت الى فتره هدوء وجيزه سمحت
بتسريع عمليات اجلاء الدبلوماسيين
والرعايه الاجانب قبل ان تشهد بدورها
اتهامات متبادله بين الجيش والدعم السريع
بخرقها في السابع والعشرين من ابريل اعلن
الطرفان موافقتهما على تمديد الهدنه
الاثنتين وسبعين ساعه جديده بعد مساء
دوليه قادتها الولايات المتحده لكن وبعد
فتره هدوء قصيره تجددت الاشتباكات بين
الطرفين لاسيما في العاصمه الخرطوم
في اخبارنا الاخرى توفي فتى فلسطيني جراء
اصابته خلال مواجهات مع قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في بلده تقوع جنوب مدينه بيت
لحم بالضفه الغربيه وقالت وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه في بيان صحفي ان الفتى الشهيد
البالغ من العمر 15 عاما اصيب برصاصه في
الصدر خلال المواجهات التي وقعت في
المنطقه الاثريه في البلده وبهذا يرتفع
عدد الشهداء في الاراضي الفلسطينيه منذ
بدايه العام الحالي الى 103
النائب المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه
ان بلاده تعارض بشده بناء اسرائيل
مستوطنات جديده
ودعا اسرائيل الى عدم اتخاذ اي خطوات تقوض
حل الدولتين
يجب على جميع الاطراف الامتناع عن الاعمال
التي تزيد من حده التوتر وتبتعد بنا عن
السلام وهذا يشمل بالتاكيد توسيع
المستوطنات واضاءه الشرعيه على بؤرها وهدم
المنازل نحن نعارض بشده بناء المستوطنات
ونحث اسرائيل على عدم اتخاذ خطوات من
شانها ان تبعدنا اكثر عن حل الدولتين
قال وزير الخارجيه الايرانيه حسين امير
عبداللهيان انه اتفق مع نظيره السعودي
فيصل بن فرحان على العمل في الايام
المقبله على اعاده افتتاح السفارات
والقنصليات في البلدين ذلك خلال مؤتمر
الصحفي لعبد اللهيان في ختام زيارته
لبيروت
خلال الاتصال الهات
فيطر مع نظير السعودي اتفقنا على العمل في
الايام المقبله لاعاده افتتاح السفارات
والقنصليات الايرانيه والسعوديه في طهران
والرياض زميله وزير الخارجيه السعودي رحب
بدعوته لزياره طهران وانا رحبت بدعوته
لزياره الرياض
محترمه وامور خارجيه اعلن الجيش الايراني
احتجازا ناقله نفط تنقل حموله تعود
ملكيتها الى الولايات المتحده وترفع علم
جزر مارشن في خليج عمان واقيادها الى
المياه الايرانيه وقال الجيش الايراني ان
الناقله اصطدمت بسفينه ايرانيه في المياه
الخليجيه ما تسبب في اصابه عدد من البحاره
وفقدان اثر اثنين واكد الجيش ان الناقله
حاولت الفرار عبر اطفاء اجهزه التتبع
وتغيير مسارها بشكل متكرر وامتناعها عن
تقديم المساعده للسفينه خلافا لقوانين
الملاحه البحريه الدوليه
اعلنت السلطات الاوكرانيه تعرض العاصمه
كييف ومقاطعات في وسط وجنوب البلاد لهجوم
روسي واسع ما ادى الى وقوع ضحايا لا سيما
في دينيبرو وعمان وسط وجنوبي البلاد وقالت
هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان الدفاعات
الجويه اسقطت 21 صاروخا من طراز كروز
اضافه الى مسيرتين
ودعت رئاسه الاوكرانيه العالم الى تطبيق
العقوبات على الدول التي تمد روسيا بمواده
ومنتجات تساعدها في الالتفاف على القيود
المفروضه عليها لانتاج مزيدا من الصواريخ
في محاوله للحفاظ على الهيمنه العالميه
عملت الولايات المتحده وحلفائها على تاكل
بنيه الامن العالمي بشكل خطير وبدروا الى
اطلاق عمليه تخريب وانهاء الاتفاقيات
الرئيسيه المتعلقه بمراقبه التسلح وتعزيز
الثقه تنفذ واشنطن مع شركائها اليوم خطتها
الاستراتيجيه المتمثله في استفزاز دول
اخرى لمواجهه عسكريه مع دول معارضه لها
وفي مقدمتها روسيا والصين والهدف الحقيقي
من هذه السياسه التي تتبعها واشنطن هو
الحاق هزيمه استراتيجيه بروسيا وتشكيل
تهديد للصين والحفاظ على مكانتها المهيمنه
في العالم
اعلنت اسره الزميل هشام عبد العزيز صحفي
في قناه الجزيره مباشر ان السلطات المصريه
الغت قرار الافراج عنه دون ابداء الاسباب
وقالت اسره الزميل هشام ان المحاميه
ابلغهم بان قرار الافراج الغي وان هشام ما
يزال محبوسا على ذمه القضيه التي تعود
لعام 2019 وهو المتهم الوحيد في هذه
القضيه واشارت الى ان هشام سيكمل اربع
سنوات في الحبس الاحتياطي بحلول شهر يونيو
المقبل دون ان يعرض على المحاكمه فيما
تتجدد فتره حبسه باستمرار دام
تغطتنا مستمره للمشهد في السودان القاكم
باذن الله على راس الساعه